everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm excited about today
starting our coverage of the 2016 World
Chess Championships between Magnus
Carlsen the reigning champion 25 year
old Ben the champion since 2013 and the
Challenger ascending a Kodiak in 26 year
old he won the 2016 candidates
tournament so they are fighting for the
world championship tournament is from
November 11th through November 28th they
essentially are going to be playing two
days take a day off play two days take a
day off we will have coverage as soon as
the match is over I'll be starting the
video and then as soon as I'm done I'll
upload that so keep an eye out for the
next few weeks to make sure that you are
keeping up with all of the coverage but
if you're not too familiar with how the
World Championship is going to go down
it's a little bit different than some of
the other tournaments for time controls
they have 100 minutes for the first 40
moves and they get a 30 seconds
increment added on after each move also
they cannot agree to a tie for the first
30 move so in some of the tournaments
you may see after even 17 moves they
kind of look and say let's not play this
out they're not gonna be doing that in
the World Championship now if there's a
threefold repetition where you have the
same bore state after three moves in
that particular case that would be a
drawing game but they can't just extend
their hand to their opponent unless it's
after 30 moves that should be exciting
we should be playing more towards
victories in this tournament less
playing for drawl so that's always good
if you're not too familiar with kind of
the history that these two players have
they've played 21 times before Magnus
Carlsen is one of four of those times
certainly at County hackin is one one of
those and they have drawn 16 at time so
that's kind of the intro Magnus Carlsen
from the opening ceremony drew and he
drew white for the first game so he's
gonna be going first in games 1 3 5 8 10
and 12 so there are 12 games or
essentially playing until someone gets
six and a half points so it could in
before that if someone goes on at
here and starts winning but that's kind
of how its set up so certainly okay
yakin will kind of do every other but
the knee does have white in Game six and
seven so that's kind of intro just so
everyone is aware of how the tournament
set up it is being played in New York
City in the United States so without
further ado we'll go ahead and get
started with game number one Magnus
Carlsen decides to start with pawn to d4
something I was not expecting to see
Magnus Carlsen typically plays a little
bit more aggressive style with pawn to
e4 of a pond to d5 maybe a little bit
slower for his taste you know we saw
this a lot from Vichy now I'm playing
pawn to d4 but really expected Magnus
Carlsen efore he's been preparing for
this tournament for many many months so
maybe he saw something particularly in
this opening so da plays Knight to f6
and then Bishop to g5 so right away
Magnus Carlsen Tron passkey opening was
not expecting this really kind of
thought pawn to c4 getting into the
Queens gambit declined line we're
certificate karyakin plays quite a bit
but Magnus Carlsen had something up his
sleeve Bishop here to f5 a pawn to d5
very common way to respond a pawn to e3
upon to c5 attacking on the Queen side
and the bishop takes here on f6 and so
typically in the trump house key opening
there's kind of this give-and-take
white's says I'll go ahead and give up
my double Bishop pawn instead I'm gonna
give you a double pawn structure and you
can keep a double Bishop on your side
and towards the end of the game I think
my pawn structures going to win out and
so Black has a few options here in the
particular game Sergey decides to go
ahead and recapture with this pawn
capturing towards the center of the
board I think this is interesting I
would have taken a little bit
differently more times than not I think
it's easier and maybe even more correct
to take pawn takes here on f6 I didn't
see a lot of that the commentaries I was
watching it myself that it kind of
glossed over and maybe said you know G
pawn takes round f6 is totally fine but
I think this is just easier to play in
general it does give a king side safety
if you want a castle on the King side
you open up the door for both your
bishops light score and dark square
you're protecting this Paul
here on c5 if there ever is a capture
maybe pawn takes here on c5 you can
easily get this evolved into the board
you can cast on the kingside very very
strong defense right here and you also
have this semi open file if your queen
wants to attack or if you castle on the
King side your rook comes over here to
e8 I really really like this attack or
defense it if you will from black but in
the game Sergey takes with his pawn here
on f6 and then the pawn takes on c5
responds from black is Knight takes on
c6 and he has a few options didn't have
to play knight on c6 but both sides up
into this point each move is taking
about 5 to 7 seconds they're not really
thinking too much so it looks like they
both prepared for this even though this
is kind of the last book move there's
not a lot of theory beyond this point
both sides seem pretty comfortable in
this opening now I think it makes sense
even to play as a pawn to e6 just
solidifying this pawn Chang opening up
the door for this dark square Bishop to
attack right here
you know White has a few options he
could try to hold on to it probably kind
of a futile way to play pawn to b4 but
then just start chipping away pawned a 5
maybe pawn to c3 take take and then pawn
to be 6 if the pawn takes you're gonna
see the bishop can come down take check
the Queen's eventually going to take
this pawn here on b6 gonna be very hard
for white to really hold down his
material and then all of a sudden you
see black really controlling the Queen
side of the board so instead they could
have tried something else instead of
pawn to b4 could have tried maybe more
aggressive approach of Queen to h5 and
then the bishop takes on c5 I think this
would have been pretty exciting both
sides of the board have a pretty strong
attack going on right now but we didn't
see this in the game we see Knight to c6
which makes a lot of sense and then the
first time where a player actually
started thinking so as we said 5 to 7
seconds to move and then sort of get hey
I can took 20 minutes for this next move
or after Bishop to b5 we see pawn to e6
and this took certainly a karyakin quite
a bit of time he had a few options here
and maybe he was expecting instead of
Bishop to b5 he's affecting Knight to c3
and then maybe respond pawn to e6 could
about his queen h5 f 5 here castle on
the Queen's how to really like this from
magnus carlsen cancelling on the Queen
Stein just throwed the entire kitchen
sink over here on the kingside
recognizing his opponents probably not
gonna castle on the Queen side just
because it's fairly open and the King
sides really his only other option list
he wants to keep his King in the center
of the board but he can really have a
strong attack here on the kingside
madness Carlsen though deciding I don't
want to do that at all played Bishop
here to b5 played it pretty fast and
then after 20 minutes serega karyakin
played pawn to e6 he could have tried
something else could have tried let's
say Queen to a5 check Knight to c3 a6
Bishop back here a4 and then maybe pawn
to e6 but says okay I don't want to get
my Queen involved into the game so I'm
just going to go and play East 6th right
away so pawn to c4 after the pawn takes
on c4 Knight to d2 Magnus Carlsen does
not want to trade off Queens this early
in the game he's playing White's it's
the first game in the World Chess
Championship he is the champion there's
no reason for him to kind of immediately
go to a draw game which is exactly what
would happen if he traded off Queens
right now so he wants to to keep that
slim advantage that he has as playing
the white pieces right now decides to go
and played Knight - a d2 so BA plays a
bishop takes on c5 just getting that
material in the knight to f3 so Magnus
Carlsen is down upon the material but
it's gonna be easy for him whatever he
wants to to go ahead and get this
material back here on c4 does have his
Bishop does have his knight both
attacking it so it's kind of there for
the taking when he wants to castle on
the Kings side a castle on the Kings
side so black does have the double
bishop pair that we talked about but he
just doesn't have as much King side
safety as Magnus Carlsen does so if
Magnus Carlsen can start to form an
attack on the Kings side could be a
little interesting how cardiac and wants
to defend that Knight to a5 trying to
hold on to
material as long as possible on c4 we
recover here to see one attacking that
material this you back here to e7 Queens
who see to putting more pressure on at
this pawn on c4 a Bishop to d7 Bishop
decides to go ahead and take here Queen
takes and then Queen up here to c3
attacking the knight that's no longer
being protected by the Queen
another option he has I like rook over
here to d1 centralizing your rooks and
you do have a discovered attack as soon
as this Knight moves up the board let's
say taking here on c4 he has a
discovered attack against the Queen just
a really nice way to control the center
of the board getting your Brooks
involved but decides to play Queen here
to c3 attacking this night here on a5
Queen down here d5 just putting more
defenders on the square here on c4
Knight decides to go ahead and take here
there's no way to really hold on to it
Magnus Carlsen says you know I don't
want to fight for it too much longer
after the Queen the sake then the rook
comes up here to c4
now this is a pretty draw a situation
we're only 17 moves into the game and
they can't draw in this particular case
but if if you look at both sides neither
of them has a really strong attack or
really a path to get there the rooks
aren't going to be able to do even too
much over here with an exposed King here
on the G file if anything I'd say Sergei
Aachen has the better minor piece the
bishop is able to control if there's to
pawn chains you have you know one over
here on the Kings side or on the Queen
side one over here on the King side
that's probably a little bit better than
Magnus Carlson's at night which usually
does better with pawn structures just on
one side of the board but it's fairly
easy for Magnus Carlsen to even get rid
of one of the pawn chains and to get his
Knight pretty active on the board
especially since there's there's two
knights on there so right now it looks
pretty Josh but you never know
especially with Magnus Carlsen he
usually likes to extend games out really
really long even if he's not playing for
this particular game he likes to wear
down his opponent so later in a
tournament when they get a little bit
tired that's kind of where he thrives so
we'll kind of see how this continues
rook over here too
ch rook to c1 we start to see some
exchange to both sides seem like they're
okay with just getting material off the
board
we're over here to d8 threatening a back
rank mates with rook to d1 you know have
the knight come down here to e1 but then
after the capture this will be game over
cymatics Carlsen rightly plays pawn to
d3 making sure we don't have any of that
rook to d7 just defending the seventh
rank for whites Magnus Carlsen really
liked his rook to come up here to c7 and
start to attack would have been
attacking the bishop here this pawn here
so I sort of go hey I can that says okay
I'm gonna go ahead and stop that right
now play rook here to a d7 Magnus
continues with the King to f1 starting
to get in this key involvement to the
game pawn to f5 King e to a bishop here
to f5 attacking the pawn pawn appear to
be three making sure that his pawns are
no longer able to be attacked on the
Queen side King here to f8 spawn h3 pawn
h6 both sides just starting to push up a
little bit on the board neither has a
really strong attack going a king to e7
so getting a skiing involved into the
action Knight here to d3 King d8 punt up
here to f4 pun h5 Ponte for a root down
here to d5 and the Magnus Carlsen is
just gonna try as Knight just move it
around as much as possible see if he can
find a weakness from a cardiac in pawn
to be six forcing the knight to move
Knight here to a6 Bishop up here to e7
Knight to be eight King or pawn to a5 my
back here a c6 King e8 Knight to e5
neither side making much much room as
far as any sort of gain it's still
pretty draw on board Bishop down to c5
very very nice outpost for this Bishop
really stops any sort of threat of the
rook getting past enemy lines and
starting to attack and now you can't
have any sort of trickery with pawn to
b4 just because you have all of these
defenders with the pawn and the bishop
right here so the Queen sides pretty
much locked down King sided is also
going to be fairly difficult for white
to really break through
but we continued magnus carlsen a rook
to c3 King e7 a rook over here to d3 we
see an exchange on board so right now
we're just getting pieces off the board
we're 36 moves in so they can draw if
they wanted to mattis cross n decides to
go ahead and play on pawns who have six
the knight moves check and we see the
knight come back here King just
continues to move forward a little bit
king c6 Knight d4 King at d6 night to b5
check and then we see a little song and
dance and then all of a sudden they
decide after 42 moves to go ahead and
draw so I was expecting maybe Magnus
Carlsen to come now a little bit more
aggressive in the first game he's had so
much preparation coming into this I
thought yes he did go outside of theory
I just expected that outside of theory
to be something different than the Tron
passkey which I just don't see him play
that often I thought maybe he'd be a
little bit more aggressive against his
opponent but Sergei hey I can keep you
know hats off to him in the very first
game against a world champion to defend
with a black pieces get that draw going
into tomorrow you have the white pieces
looking for the win there so all in all
really excited about this tournament I
think it's gonna be extremely extremely
we have two young players 25 and 26
years old Magnus Carlsen actually turns
26 on November 30th so if there's it's
high breaker he will be playing for the
championship on his 26th birthday but I
think both these guys can play 12 games
and never really get tired since they
are so young so it should be really
exciting hopefully you guys are excited
about the World Chess Championship as
well make sure you all stay tuned every
day for coverage as well but thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video